dernier mot sur ce point puis on va
passer à tenir en fait parce que disait
alain juppé à un moment donné en disant
qu'il fallait
comment dire il fallait mener de bout de
l'homme lindsey les deux bouts de
l'omelette et lui garder le milieu et
donc je pense que ça c'est effectivement
le surnomme le pari de macron pour les
européennes
la seule chose c'est que un certain
nombre de députés république et un bus
mis qu'un faut remarquer que ensuite
s'il faut quand même choisir un groupe
pour siéger à strasbourg et que là il
faudra quand même qu emmanuel macron
mais hélas il ya le ppe et le pse est
bon ensuite il ya les libéraux donc le
côté est de droite et de gauche des
manuels macron qui a bien marché en
france jusqu'à présent tout